Assassin's Creed is officially part of
the Final Fantasy 15 canon it turns out
that noctis and Prompto are huge fans of
the ubisoft series and this clip shows
them freaking out over an assassin's
creed festival so where does this rank
among the rest of the file fantasy 15
DLC give us your opinion in the comments
below and while you're here give us a
like and subscribe for the latest on all
things gaming
gotcha
you
we'll be arriving shortly gentlemen Wow
satins festival here we come I'm so
hyped I can't believe it's finally here
need I remind you there's an imperial
bounty on your head keep it in check
fine come on let him have some fun it
ain't easy being a wanted man boo boo
look at all these posters it's happening
isn't it
it's really happening what's got these
two so excited all of a sudden the two
of them happened to be rather fond of
the Assassin's Creed series he would be
too if he played it
man is this incredible or what it's
definitely different than usual look at
all these people it's like they
assassinated our plans of having fun at
the festival and mark my words I'm gonna
make sure they pay for it they heard
anything from Agnes yeah they've got the
regalia surrounded Jimmy a break first
we get Holly then the car right I'll
tell Iggy we'll meet up with them later
if you think I'd let you leave that hunk
of junk in my plant you better think
again you can't come in here and
manhandle our power supply it takes a
woman's touch which is why we require
your assistance as if I would agree your
position does not afford you the right
to protest well if you insist have your
men return my key cards can't monitor
the inner workings of the plant from the
outside you will be permitted access as
necessary follow my orders and all will
be well we provide you with peace and
yet still you rebel it is high time you
learn to show some gratitude and to know
your place as our lowly subjects
take her away let's go after her
no we just be putting her in more danger
and what are we supposed to do I never
said I had a better idea but I did hear
her say Loki's men stole her key carts I
mean we could start by stealing them
back okay then let's split up and take
him down
nothing's working on these guys time to
turn tail
[Music]
[Music]
better they'll oh you okay yeah I think
so
I'm worried about the others then let's
head back they've blocked off the main
entrance in that case we just find a new
one
it was like my attacks just stopped
working all of a sudden and sounds like
they employed some sort of jamming
device one that prevents you unleashing
your power to its full potential
great our only option is to infiltrate
the power plant and interrupt the
Empire's interference without the power
of Kings on our side but who needs the
power of Kings when you have the power
of assassins I get to be an assassin
well they have no other choice then it's
settled
our first order of business should be to
gather a bit more Intel knocked you and
pronto should scout out Loki's
subordinates from the tower in front of
the main thoroughfare got it ah is there
anything I can do nothing I can't put
you in harm's way
but my friends in harm's way right now I
want to do whatever I can to help sounds
like you won't take no for an answer
anyway if anything comes up we'll let
you know indeed